Once in a while we get these legendary
creatures that are really freaking cool,
but they're just not quite there. I find
this to be quite common with second
commanders from precons. Man, I remember
trying for ages to make Basandra work.
That failed. Have you got something like
this? Did you manage to make it work?
Please let me know. But today we'll make
something happen. Just watch. Because
Strixhaven just brought us the newest
installment of underwhelming second
commander, Scryb. I was looking at the
art long before the release of the card
and there's just something about the
combination of black and white, such a
nice unique aesthetic. But when they
spoiled the card and everyone was
whelmed. I mean, you read this giant
block of text and ah, that sounds kind
of cool. And then you try to think of
the implications and there just isn't
much. Reminds me of those cards that
they nerf at the last minute. Two life
really isn't much of a deterrent. They
wouldn't care if they're going tall.
Yes, I'll pay two life to smack you for
18. And if they're going wide, you won't
have time to contract everything. They
can just send the uncontracted ones at
you. And they're not even forced to
attack. Yeah, in the age of gold, this
just feels really outdated. Commander
eccentric to the rescue. With this kind
of deck building, the first and easiest
thing to ask about any new legend is if
I were to blink it over and over and
over again, would it be worth it? And
the answer here is yeah, maybe. Maybe.
But even that is better than whatever we
had to begin with. With this premise,
we'll be able to set multiple contracts
a turn, which can trigger constellation
effects, area effects. Okay, seems good.
Also, we have a creature entering the
battlefield over and over again, which
does trigger a few things.
But that's about it.
And it doesn't quite do enough, I felt.
Cuz constellation and area, they do have
a few gems, but it's quite limited
within our colors and the base form is
just we are spending one card per
contract. Yeah, and card draw is going
to be a problem. So, we just need a
little more payoff. As is, it's not
working. We're close. We're close. But
then I saw the flying and death touch.
Flying is cool, but death touch? I mean,
it is the best combination for blocking.
I see Baleful Strix holding the fort for
almost entire games. But with our three
toughness, most fights will be a trade.
Unless, what if we replace the blink
spells with these undying effects? You
know, Supernatural Stamina, Undying
Malice, Feign Death, Not Dead After All,
and of course, Malakir Rebirth. Some of
these return the creatures tapped, but
it's hard to say no to the single skull
mana. Two mana is also decent and we get
some added bonus like treasures. And
there's one three mana instant in Sign
in Blood. I don't actually know how good
this card will be, but I just wanted it
in every deck. And that's not it because
we're looking like a bit of an
enchantress deck, so auras is where it's
at. Changing Loyalty is a sweet new card
and fits straight in. Kaya's Ghostform
is a classic and Minions' Return is kind
of crappy, but it also shows the lowest
point we're willing to go for synergy.
These reanimation effects are also
solid. The real bomb here is Gift of
Immortality. This is one of those cards
so pushed, they haven't made anything
even remotely close for a decade and
probably won't for another. And it's
perfect for this deck. Nim Deathmantle
is much worse in a vacuum, but still
makes the cut for reusability. And how
about that? Yeah, go ahead, attack into
this. You will lose your best attacker
and serve as our sac outlet. Okay, that
seems decent. Our commander is now a top
tier blocker if the situation calls for
it. So, this way we can We can feel
pretty safe from the combat phase. Yeah,
we can deter most attacks.
But this, of course, has another little
hoop we have to jump through. Sac
outlets. Luckily, we do have some really
high quality lands for that and outside
of these, we are only taking the best of
the best. Warren Soul Trader, Phyrexian
Altar, and Attrition just to have some
removals in a pinch. Erebos and, of
course, Yawgmoth. And with that, it also
kind of solves our card draw problem
because black. And now, finally, I think
we have a solid foundation and we can
give it a go and enjoy the payoffs.
Since we're having enchantment tokens
enter consistently, why not double them?
Roaming Throne and Dawn are nice because
they double the ETB trigger, but also
the attack trigger. Anointed Procession
and Mondrak, they don't do that, but
there's incidental value here and there
like copying treasure tokens, for
example. Also, Mondrak can serve as a
sac outlet in a pinch.
Ondu Spirit Dancer works with all
enchantments and that can lead to some
magical Christmas land scenarios. Okay,
now the actual payoffs. There are some
sweet ones, but let's start simple.
Every enchantment deck begins with
Sphere of Safety. And we ramp up with
Ajani's Chosen, Archon of Sun's Grace,
and Ghostly Dancers. These are pretty
costly, but they can go out of hand
pretty quickly once we have our
enchantment engine set up. Doomwake
Giant and Thought Render Lamia are the
top end of our payoffs, clearing our
opponents' boards and hands if they're
allowed to stick for a turn or two.
Also, graveyards too, why not? We can
get so many triggers that even Grim
Guardian might be worth it. But the best
payoff and what makes me most excited
about this deck is these. Yeah, these
powerhouses probably all better aura
commanders than this derp who they're
now working under. Harry Maguire vibes
for those of you into football. But
yeah, getting one of these down will
hypercharge our game plan. And finally,
Arden. When the time is right, we strap
10 contracts onto Scryb to one-shot them
idiots for somehow letting us build up
to 10 contracts. Magical Christmas land,
I know, but it's still kind of fun to
move these contracts to new, more
relevant creatures. Oh, nice Blightsteel
you've got there. Let's sign these. And
what I consider to be the ultimate
payoff, Skybind. Okay, this might not be
broken broken, but it's really fun the
moment you get this down with our
commander. We are blinking on every
opponent's turn and we are going to be
obnoxious about it. See, I know you're
comboing off, but let me trigger my
constellation first. And also, combined
with the other enchantments in the deck,
you can do a lot of political work. You
can disrupt your opponents because you
can target any creature. Yeah, there's
going to be a lot of versatility here
and it will be the funnest time you have
playing this deck. We do need to keep
the card advantage up. For card draw, we
have Agent Venom, Enduring Innocence,
Caretaker's Talent, and of course,
Skullclamp. Brazen Borrower Nightmare is
actually broken in multiplayer. Sac an
aura and we're most likely drawing three
cards a turn. Pitiless Charge, we can
just sac a few auras to refill our hand.
And Bontu is nice because we can reuse
it over and over again. Ramp here is
nothing special. Worth mentioning is
Relic of Legends. Every time Scryb gets
brought back untapped, it can basically
refund us one mana. And that can add up.
And Soulstone in the late game is like
our last resort for reanimating Scryb
and other engines of the deck.
Expedition Map and Weathered Wayfarer,
of course, to look for our sac outlet
lands and there's always Land Tax. For
lands, we do have a decent amount of
room for utility. Just make sure we have
five or six basics to not whiff with
Land Tax or a random Path to Exile.
We've got all the staples for card draw
and graveyard hate. The Final Fantasy
adventure lands both have decent synergy
with the deck, so they're in. And the
enchantment matters lands like Hall of
Heliod's Generosity. Velgoth Slayer
happens to be an enchantment. In terms
of play experience, this deck should be
a bit slow. It requires some setup
before actually making any kind of
impact. It's fairly resilient with the
recursion and card draw that are built
in. The deck shouldn't be too
complicated to play. Just remember your
triggers. For budget, it's sitting
around $500 for a near full power
version. Can we go budget? I think so
because none of these cards here above
$20 are really necessary. The lands are
replaceable and the doublers are kind of
win more sometimes. And sac outlets.
Okay, sac outlets are the biggest losses
here, but we can make do with some
budget options there. There's a bunch.
These big payoffs and win conditions are
not expensive and the engine is, again,
bulk of bin stuff. So, yeah, I can see
this being very buildable for around
$100.
Uh in terms of bracket, it can push
bracket three maybe if you if you want
to add some GCs. But I see this sitting
at a high bracket two, low bracket three
at best. Although, do keep in mind this
is a new card, so I haven't done the
testing I usually do with my deck lists.
And that's all. Thank you for watching
the video all the way through. If you
enjoy this kind of video, feel free to
give it a like and follow along for
future content. I'm trying to stick to a
consistent schedule and I've got a few
years worth of weekly deck lists I'm
excited to share with you guys. So,
please let me know if you plan to build
a deck like this. How does it go if you
do? This is Jin with Next Level
Commander and I will see you around.